[Music]
when your dad is on the sports
Entertainment Mount Rushmore
[Applause]
it's going to be a unique ride
it's Cody Rhodes right there that's
Dusty's boy he always wanted to be like
that
to create your own path is extremely
difficult
his NXT kids can be his kids but I'm one
of his actual kids I did not let him
call himself Cody Rhodes does that make
sense
being madly
I knew I had to get out if you build it
they will come
Vince McMahon flew to his house to get
him back I don't know how many people
can say they did that it's a fresh start
for the American Nightmare get a dream
hold on to it and shoot from the sky
this is my one request I don't want
edited in any capacity don't even edit
this part
foreign